ever since the january 6th attack
thousands of national guard troops have
been stationed at the u.s
capitol their mission to protect the
building and those who work there
but one soldier has been busy with a
side pursuit
trying to meet all 100 u.s senators
before his tour of duty came to an end
congressional correspondent chris van
cleave has his story
at a time when signs of division are as
plain as the fences
ringing the nation's capital enough is
enough
and about the only thing lawmakers seem
to agree on
washington is completely different yield
is that they
don't agree obstruction obstruction
obstruction
new york national guard sergeant first
class vincent scalise
started a mission that would bring
republicans and democrats together i
first
ran into susan collins and then amy
klobuchar and i took pictures of both of
them and when i was showing it to
my operations officer he was like why
don't you try getting a picture with all
100 senators
over the next six weeks scalise became a
fixture in these halls of democracy
his progress tracked on social media as
he used his off time to snag
senator selfies who was the hardest
senator to find senator rush
from idaho he doesn't like getting his
picture taken
the idaho republican took three tries
before stopping
for this picture every senator i met was
extremely nice
they would take a photo and then before
they ran off they would still ask where
you're from how you were doing it
last shift approaching the end of his
tour in washington
scalise needed some help i really got
nervous that you know we were going to
leave before i could finish
louisiana republican bill cassidy and
delaware democrat chris coons jumped in
they were actually calling senators
offices for me and setting up
appointments for me to go meet with him
so
did mississippi republican cindy
hyde-smith i went in the democratic
caucus room they looked to me like what
are you doing in here and i said
i came after you helping track down the
final dozen
during the all-night debate over covet
relief going on the senate floor and
saying look you're coming with me
this guy out here has a uniform on he
wants a picture and you're going to do
it
oregon's jeff merkley number 100. it was
great it was like winning a race
like coming across the finish line if a
picture is worth a thousand words
scalise's photos tell a story of coming
together
just as so much is pulling us apart i
feel like after this that there's hope
for bipartisanship up here
yeah i i do believe that and i believe
there's hope
for the whole country not just here
returning home to his wife and two kids
in utica
this citizen soldier can claim the
rarest of victories in congress
finding something everyone could agree
on
for cbs this morning saturday chris van
cleave
washington nicely done i know fantastic
great piece and it really does give me
hope